housing going brass my name I don't know
if I should take this serene or not
maybe I should I don't know that much
all right I'm doing that ah that is not
good Oh like I even haven't cut one
there's a baton here I was thinking I
don't know if it's now I can't it would
have been so I pick to dual wield batons
come on pick it up
I don't have space anyway I have space
why did I use my serene then son of ass
alright at least we can quickscope and
[ __ ] like that alright so let's go down
here shall we I think we are pretty
freakin screwed by that freaking head in
the beginning that make me really all
right whatever let's just get this [ __ ]
oh no it's this again I don't like this
I don't think anyone likes this I'm
gonna pick up myself doing just because
of it
alright let's just run this yes yes
they're talking about me I mean saying I
get it
I'm taking phone pictures pictures they
fight they cook so neocon you're my only
friend I love you so much you never quit
on me now team if we swim in water
I'm a little sad that this game might
end soon I hope it lasts forever but
nothing lasts forever
that is how it is right so near exam yet
for their parent now we're not forever
not even me not even you son Action Man
what should I do when you die I don't
know be cool enough but I'm not I know
better you're freakin lame what did you
say son action nothing all right
god damn you well I think we're almost
done with this card I think okay extra
medication how do you think my life Sony
Ericsson I don't know I think you need
it what I don't need anything okay so
let's run this last little little part
here I think this should probably not
there's none more the linac I would be
so scared of this chainsaw guy comes
here freaking chainsaw guy oh no I
forgot thank God alright alright I get
it right guys thank God rain on my
tennis right not annoying
what do i do i do i do a my tongue it's
my tongue oh you fell they should grin
my down [ __ ] right you tipsy right
kidding left kitty stop smacking me holy
god damn I hate you
those are traps so slow I nod [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you back up back up back the [ __ ]
up
it's ahead of us but oh you slap it in
me Wow
I will ride yet I would right here let's
go to mod arts one does not stop this
slapping Holly [ __ ] freaking MLG at
slapping did you see all my loads I am
impressed
well done well I can only mean one thing
I'll see you in a couple minutes cuz I
have to replay this alright bring it
Strega I hate this shut up
[Music]
- quiet be quiet holla beer whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa they are not
but how Jeff Mason stops having it stop
slapping me now for this nonsense
sup this / flippy all right here comes a
difficult fight jump up with those
[ __ ] it didn't work son of a [ __ ]
I guess I have to prepare but the baton
and then just go for it bring it bring
it
oh I'm curious now I'm not just like
there we go one down
stop puppeteers clapping stop all of
this slapping nonsense there we go oh
[ __ ] they're actually kind of powerful
question is if I can use my m60 I think
I wasted all the ammo yep isn't that
lovely
I think they have a problem here is as
you sure I have a problem
look he's moving at once his techniques
all right the picnic stops
slapping slapping slapping slapping
slapping the bass slapping the bass
still up at a mass up at a fast
slappy slappy slappy wow there's so bad
I wasn't that bad there I mean I slept
pretty good all right let's keep
slapping I suppose bring out all of
yours
come here betcha
this is my don't [ __ ] with me face back
out
oh one shot dead nice oh you shot that
bring it [ __ ]
come on come on
Swan left back bang alright save you for
[ __ ] salon my central focus all right
now comes these little [ __ ] they are
the problems Honda let's jet
all right come here brass that's right
you're not a turtle as you can pretend
all you want
what
is that an [ __ ] what what I thought I
was doing so well - I know
let's try slant sees push includes the
drugs
all right don't judge me for this all
right there we go
use the gun it's a gun there we go Brad
come here Charles [ __ ]
now you go you think your title huh
I get it I got it one for now it's kid I
wanted me a body but now I cut it
let's go oh I hate that [ __ ] where do I
go where this one goes
Oh run like keep runnin keep runnin keep
runnin keep runnin keep runnin keep
runnin I don't think that after me
anymore I think we're good see you later
sayonara [ __ ] whoa you'd not supposed
to have a face holy [ __ ] is anyone else
water [ __ ] with me huh huh
I just had a wow I did all that for
nothing for a freaking fuse no someone
had a series's period Asia there I'm
still having the latter 400 the fuses
now I know now I know what we must what
one must do what the hell is up with
this room blood everywhere
it's fine [ __ ] freaking me alright
alright alright let's check this Gemma
won't budge well isn't that a freaking
oh that's for the fuse I am disappoint
mm-hmm okay so what we must do now is
basically
why do we put the fuse that's a question
that one must ants can't grill oh look
at yes Hey look at that did you see that
did anyone see that
I saw it fire extinct okay good good
price so I think we need to go down in
the basement actually I don't remember
correctly I think at least just we put
the ladder here yes all right like about
the question is where we used to feel
one does not simply know where to put
the fuse hey police balloon lab I see
you're still hanging out it's calling
all that your friends I really like it I
was worried about you police me I saw
that you didn't have many friends at
school I'm really happy for you okay so
I was told that there was like a serene
here somewhere but can't really see it
safety safety okay what to say today
boom yeah more assembly the whole
commune in providin they've ever learned
about phlogiston Berea I see what they
did there
alright bike are you still gonna not
ride me you little [ __ ]
where do we do this I don't know I don't
know maybe we're using the lighter too
soon
yeah that door won't budge isn't that a
shame
maybe I totally forgot where this one
simply plays bad always bad why do I put
if yours is I mean this doesn't feel
right look right here
[Music]
Wow
now I don't want to go back there no
senorita fill the Congo let me see you
move like a couple long yeah check
mighty all right
hailer how you burn it turns out I
pretty much have to go back the old way
that I thought but there's just one
little problem
merlocks why can't we just get along all
of you I don't have that much ammo
actually I pretty much have close to
nothing Emma
so I mean quite the dilemma right here I
wish I didn't waste all my M on those
all now and music just make it even more
fantastic I like my locks I'm gonna save
it because I will most likely [ __ ]
die alright I see you'll really enjoy
that head movement I get it
you're part of this group dance maybe
perhaps starting a boy band could be
something for the future right now I'm
outta here [ __ ]
no hey don't eat TT me holy [ __ ] why
would you do that
back off alright so that means plan X X
really pelvis slappy eyes shut one does
not simply smack there we go alright
that makes one of you I kill your friend
oh you're angry about your fan aren't
you I bathe in your anger come here you
little [ __ ]
[Music]
I was stuck I couldn't do anything I
couldn't even Patong him alright so that
plan didn't work I guess I have to
Patong them all individually isn't that
lovely
alright come here
come here Italia woman wham-o your anger
now hide that I know yet how would make
you angry oh we tried to lick me I like
that
[ __ ] if you jump it takes like so much
stamina come on charge it
i'ma charge no senorita no no no no you
do not simply maybe it's best if I
choose one of them just for fun
are you dead now are you that now
are you dead now there we go is that now
there we go ah [ __ ] me that's all I got
well that's it's a problem if I only can
get past like him come on bring it big
the best you got
Oh No merlok evolved into some oh no no
no alright there we go there we go
fantastic hello hi to all of you I'm
just gonna lovely totally have a I love
the decoration on the walls all right
which way from this way I think I can
still hear those little [ __ ] well I
didn't go so bad I only wasted a couple
mo and stuff like that so alright so we
need to go back all this way
[Music]
so in towns where the [ __ ] is it it's
over here oh there we go oh no back in
the water isn't that lovely
look at that alright at least I know I'm
safe here oh my luck evolved into a
fatty that's what you get
I see what it is now that net is to try
to hide this obesity I see that [ __ ] all
right we made it we [ __ ] made it
alright so now we need to go today
either be out we should definitely say
they're not choosing us I don't have to
sing but I'll sing anyway can't read ma
kerima no you can read in the mouth Oh
her face she's got me like nobody can't
read my can't read my no you can readin
I'm sorry I don't know why I do this
I believe L hidin policeman alright so
we need to go in here we have a long
walk in front of us that's all I'm gonna
say isn't that back to the subway pretty
much and put the fuse I would probably
never guess Oh
can't you just go away
mr. plan what I do it again she's I
don't know pretty what there's supposed
to be a SWAT team leader holy [ __ ] can't
we just [ __ ] me I don't have any ammo I
don't have anything charge [ __ ]
oh I stopped with the face all right
tell your baby to [ __ ] stop slapping
people
holy [ __ ] knows nothing about
all right it's over here she's was
stopped clay complaining ah don't trap
and grace see what I did
alright here's the exit isn't that
fantastic we made it when barely I'm out
of my house
oh yes yes come oh they tricked me it's
a [ __ ] flag now there we go
alright look there we go
electric lock are you [ __ ] kidding me
but I have a fear us what what no no no
no no no nah wait let me shake here did
he have two fuses that son of a [ __ ] no
senorita feel the Congo no two yet Wow
where did you get the other fuse
I need another fierce ah that's a fail
alright whatever I'll do it in the next
episode fantastic how do I walk in all
that way for nothing
anyway I can't favorite if you enjoy
subscribe to become a bro today and I'll
see you next episode
[Music]
oh boy sobs you friggin could get out of
here no there's no thought there are so
many people out there that I don't know
I want to help you bros out they simple
as that so if you